hi guys happy day today I hope you're
all having a wonderful day I'm packing
up myself and the dog and we're overing
over to max he sucks do not match but
it's all I could find out it's Matt's
birthday today today it's currently
Wednesday August 3rd there's a really
great chance that you're watching this
video and it is not August 3rd Cathy
socks are awful got all of the dogs
items I've got my items to book bags one
for dog one for me they're gonna be so
mad at me because I'm late
uber drivers aren't really a fan of when
I have the dog but like he's so good
that you don't even know he's there oh
just something I'm reviewing for Chuck
Tuesday
but it is your light three hours
straight out we believe in like three
hours
let's go through musters Fermat's your
birthday happy birthday thank you
we listen to Shawn Mendes for you oh
you're coming yes sure I think we just
come in thank you sounds like you fun of
me - you said you just come today the
bus or see listen man I'm hungry
you can eat I want to eat - that's okay
I too need a little snack we're taking
Matt somewhere for Anna's birthday
dinner somewhere that you guys have seen
us blog before matter of the watch our
vlog
i watch your videos and your unboxing
beside it we're getting from appetizers
we're gonna get some drinks I don't
let's drop my camera
and they go order to many advertisers
there's only three of us and we're going
to dinner soon
is there supposed to be a small snack
so the other day I'm s birthday party
Jenna and that basically dominated the
beer pong table the entire
I told you I'm gonna show these fools
what's up
just like quick little trip today now
we're heading home Emad e and then we're
gonna be taking Matt to a secret
restaurant destination nice outfit
we're matching I didn't bring anything
else except the sweater it has a hole in
it so really classing up this drawing
we're on our way now it's Matt's secret
birthday dinner Ed's here
why sure
Martin GE you guys talked about this
place yeah I think I could just scoot up
in that thing let's scoot up in that
thing scoop it's really dark in here we
finally made it
lobster Pop Tarts
like a little shirt well sure amigo
the boss got me off yes Wow Wow I get
light there's sweet chili sriracha aioli
the basket comes out you guys can pass
it around and the popcorn is edible as
well and you've got it in my basic salad
your sparkler you can't
how's it going got this great shirt on
today cuz today I wanted to chat with
you guys about the Instagram stories